last night at a CNN Town Hall Florida
Senator Marco Rubio you might have seen
it walked into the Lions Den with a
filet mignon in his back pocket if I
believed that that law would have
prevented this from happening I would
support it but I want to explain to you
why you would not senator Rubio
it's hard to look at you and not look
down the barrel of an ar-15 or not look
at Nicholas Cruz can you tell me right
now that you will not accept a single
donation from the NRA that's why I
support the things that I have stood for
in Rubio was really gutsy to show up and
to hear the kids out but sure wasn't fun
and he quickly became a punching bag for
the crowd and the questioners there was
booing they were jeering a complete lack
of respect by teenagers as well as the
adults in the room who frankly should
have known better
Dana lash the NRA spokes woman received
her own warm sienna and welcome think of
how far you you all could go as a result
of voicing your beliefs you can shout me
down when I'm finished but let me answer
in this question as other media networks
would have covered it
[Music]
he should not have been able to purchase
the firearm naturally the media lapped
up all this nastiness and there was
basically zero criticism of the hecklers
who showed zero respect for the public
officials and the spokespeople who
actually showed up for a real dialogue
maybe get something positive
accomplished instead the people on that
stage were walked into the middle of
Nero's circus I was thinking about this
now imagine if conservative students in
the audience had screamed horrible
things at Democrat Senator Bill Nelson
when he made this tendentious point did
you know that the state of Florida the
governor's office gave financial
incentives for the Colt corporation to
come to Kissimmee to manufacture ar-15
the same one that wrecked such havoc
that wreak such havoc okay well what
Nelson conveniently left out was that
despite the financial incentives Colt
never actually moved its ar-15 factory
to Florida and also think about this
what is so horrible about encouraging
manufacturers of legal products to come
into your state to create jobs so is a
governor who for instance offers tax
breaks to a distillery responsible for
the actions of every drunk driver that
happens to drink that beverage I think
not well CNN was not alone and they're
completely politicized and biased
coverage the AP the Washington Post and
many others in the media felt compelled
to create card game oh look at that yes
Donald Trump held a note card during a
White House listening session there was
a lot made of the notes that he had on a
piece of paper sort of outlining the
sort of the steps of empathy as if the
President had to be reminded to
empathize there was this awkward photo
today from The Associated Press showing
the notes that the president brought
with him to talk to these kids and their
families who
been through gun massacres now this is
how desperate the presses the president
holds an unprecedented open forum with
students with teachers and shooting
survivors and this is something they
would have praised Obama to the hill for
I mean you've never seen anything like
what you saw yesterday and I should hope
that the president walks into an event
like this which is so emotional
everybody's watching really prepared and
if he had no notes they would have
complained that Oh Trump just winged it
and he clearly just doesn't care at all
about the kids the anti-gun activist
they have every right to make their
pitch to ban weapons if that's what they
really believe but I'll tell you one
thing they are not entitled to their own
facts they routinely claim for instance
that the NRA
is against background checks well this
was the NRA 'he's wayne lapierre
at CPAC today the National Rifle
Association originated the National
instant check system
it was our bill no one on the prohibited
persons list should ever have access to
a firearm no killer
no felon no drug dealer I think my
friend Jake Tapper didn't focus on that
last night but nevertheless the
president tweeted his support of the
organization today saying among other
things the folks who work so hard at the
NRA are great people and great American
patriots they love our country and will
do the right thing well this sent the
lowbrow lefties into paroxysms of
outrage because they want our young
people to think of the NRA as a
reprehensible bloodthirsty organization
evil people who are you know in the
words of one of the kids at CNN
terrorists Trump was pushing the NRA
line today I thought talking about
emotional problems which of course
that's the soft it doesn't heal with
guns that's the traditional Republican
way and that's the NRA way that the NRA
bought the NRA Bach politician
again I cannot stress this enough the
Democrats and their leftist enablers in
the media are positively desperate to
distract you from all the
good news that's happening around us
think about this a new poll out just
this week by Gallup tells us that 45% of
Americans are satisfied with our
standing in the world
that's a 13-year high and it's also a 13
percentage point increase from just a
year ago small business confidence is
way up the economy is strong and so all
the Democrats can do in response is to
create new boogeyman so before it was
the bogus hysteria over Russian
collusion and now it's the NRA for a
year they've tried to peddle contempt
for President Donald Trump but today
after all that work by the meeting the
left his approval numbers are higher
than they were when he was elected the
generic Republican versus Democrat
ballot is also tightening this is
incredible some of the GOP have the GOP
now within three points of the Democrats
the Democrats led by double digits just
two months ago so I say they're sure the
country still has problems yeah drug
addiction violence and cities like
Chicago and Baltimore the spread of
ms-13 and now we know really know the
need to improve school safety but
generally things are getting better
they're getting better for more
Americans and this is driving Democrats
absolutely bonkers so much so that
they're even willing to exploit the pain
of the young Stoneham Douglass High
School survivors now I'd like to say
that I was surprised by this but I'm not
many on the Left elected officials
professional activists and those who
fund them have been doing this kind of
thing for decades in order to create
this socialist utopia that they all
envision they have tried to convince the
people our people in this country the
citizens to sacrifice their individual
rights their basic freedoms for the
common good
a few more taxes here a few more
regulations there and now they want our
water down the Second Amendment on the
false promise that to do so will be an
end to all these school killings we
won't have any school killings anymore
but I say we should be very careful here
the
the administrative State wants to take
away guns using tragedies as excuses
because they don't want the private
individual to have personal power as Ben
Franklin once wrote those who would give
up Essential Liberty to purchase a
little temporary safety deserve neither
liberty nor safety and that's the angle